two movies I'm excited about this
weekend our show dogs and Deadpool -
what can I say I happen to like both
talking animals and cursing comic-book
superheroes this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
this week's top ticket is great for the
entire family show dog starring Will
Arnett this family comedy features an
unlikely pairing of a human detective
and his canine partner who have to go
undercover at the world's most exclusive
dog show and recruit an all-star cast of
animal helpers to solve their biggest
case yet it's basically Miss
Congeniality but with talking dogs show
dogs just for you if you're looking to
get your lap on with the entire family
this weekend you're a fan of talking
animal movies like scooby Doo or Beverly
Hills Chihuahua or you like German crime
dramas like Silence of the Lambs or
seven but are curious what those would
look like a little less dark what's in
the bog what's in the box
dog toys tug toys are in the box I got
this you waited for me to get back into
that video not only is this movie full
of hilariously cute moments but it's
also full of a great cast in addition to
Will Arnett you get Chris Ludacris
bridges as the voice of Max natasha
Lyonne from Orange is the new black is
Matty gabriel iglesias aka fluffy as
sprinkles and Shaq as the voice of karma
Deadpool 2 hits theaters this weekend is
the second installment in Marvel's
edgier r-rated an action comedy comic
book character movie series slash
technically the 11th installment in the
x-men film franchise hey Deadpool aka
Wade Wilson teams up with some mutant
badasses as x-force to save a mutant kid
from the time-traveling warrior soldier
cable roofer die
this movie is for you if you love Marvel
movies with it Twista uncensored r-rated
language and violence big time
action sequences or any and everything
Ryan Reynolds this one was definitely a
money grab big time the good news is you
don't need to see Deadpool one to
understand Deadpool - but definitely see
spider-man three to enjoy it yet again
we are reminded that Deadpool and Ryan
Reynolds are a perfect match
this self-aware action comedy is also
great for the entire family if your
family is all adults and can handle the
words oh and that is your weekend ticket
leave a comment below if you had 20
seconds to talk to your dog and have him
understand you and would you tell him
and be sure to check back next week for
the latest in the star wars story so low
a Star Wars story
[Music]